[Music]
In the middle means this is how we are, in the middle a
Kishan Ganga river flows and on its opposite
side is Pakistan It feels very amazing
and the climate here is also
quite different Do you not find a place like this
Other Where in India I Don't
Think There Are Places You Can and Interact with
People You Can Wow at Dem [
Music] The
Other Side
Pakistan Occupied Kashmir Thoughts Already
Developed A Lot of Dera Lets of Hotel But Nothing Else
Over Here No Recent Step Has Been
Taken  Open tourism and promote
tourism on this place I think
[Music]
Since there is pace here, whatever is happening is happening
because of peace
[Music] [
Music]
Seeing the increasing tourism here, I
recently  Not adventure awards
but the local boys here
who had no scope
also got employment because of me. [Music] How soft is the border, how much meaning is there, there
is beauty here, so we have to explore it
so that people come here, we are  If we
want this, it means that more and more
people should come in this, so we will request this from you also
[Music]